Trascrizione: rosanna valente
Revisore: Michele Gianella
A che cosa serve la matematica?
Venite con me, e cercheremo di spiegarlo.
Per fare questo,
torniamo indietro nel tempo di 34 anni.
Pensate a una giornata milanese,
di novembre, di quelle uggiose:
una classe intenta a risolvere
degli esercizi di matematica.
Ad un certo punto Paolo, uno studente,
rivolge la stessa domanda -
"A che cosa serve la matematica?" -
alla sua prof, cioè a me.
A quel tempo, quella domanda,
mi sembrò una di quelle
da un milione di dollari.
Istintivamente, risposi:
la matematica serve ad essere liberi,
e a diventare persone migliori.
Vi vedo poco, ma sono sicura
che voi farete lo stesso sguardo
dei miei studenti, allora.
A diventare persone migliori?
Certo!
E perché questo succede?
E perché non si capisce?
Perché si assegna sempre alla matematica
un'utilità di tipo pratico, materiale;
mentre si lascia alle discipline
artistiche, e umanistiche,
il resto.
Ma la matematica è un ponte.
È un ponte tra le discipline
scientifiche e tecniche,
perché utilizza la logica
come metodo di processo,
e le materie umanistiche, artistiche,
perché immagina e descrive
mondi possibili.
Ancora una volta vi stupirete,
ma voglio dirvi
che l'elemento fondamentale
della matematica è la creatività.
La creatività, direte?
Ecco: pensate a un teorema.
Quando noi immaginiamo
o studiamo un teorema,
ci focalizziamo sulla dimostrazione.
A nessuno viene in mente la domanda:
da dove è arrivato quell'enunciato?
Bene, quell'enunciato è arrivato
dalla mente di un matematico
o di una matematica,
che ha avuto un'ispirazione,
esattamente come un'artista
davanti a una tela bianca,
che immagina nella
propria mente il disegno
e poi, con sapienza,
lo fa diventare un capolavoro.
La stessa cosa succede allo scultore
davanti a un blocco informe di marmo,
o in questa bellissima cornice
davanti a un compositore,
o a un cuoco che deve fare un capolavoro.
Ecco: la matematica è creatività.
I matematici e le matematiche, cosa fanno?
Immaginano una congettura
che è frutto solo della loro mente,
slegata dalla realtà;
e poi cominciano a dimostrarla.
Magari non ci riescono loro,
ci riusciranno altri o altre dopo;
e a quel punto, quando sarà dimostrato,
sarà diventato un capolavoro
perché sarà per tutte,
per tutti, e per sempre.
A volte, con gli studenti, dico:
meglio di un diamante, regalate un teorema
quando volete fare
una dichiarazione d'amore.
Allora, la matematica
è di tutte e di tutti.
Perché non ha confini, se ci pensate,
né di religione né di genere
né politici né geografici:
ci unisce.
La matematica ci rende liberi
dagli stereotipi e dai condizionamenti.
Ci fa provare che cosa vogliamo essere,
non condizionati dagli altri,
dalle persone che ci vogliono
fare decidere quello che vogliono loro.
Per convincervi di questo,
vi faccio questo esempio:
Martina, 30 anni, single,
molto intelligente
e senza peli sulla lingua,
laureata in filosofia.
Da studentessa si interessò ai problemi
della discriminazione
e della Giustizia sociale,
e partecipò alle
manifestazioni antinucleari.
Adesso vi faccio questa domanda:
è più probabile che Martina
sia una cassiera di banca,
o sia una cassiera di banca femminista?
L'87% delle persone -
è stato fatto un esperimento, in America -
rispondono: una cassiera
di banca femminista!
Ma se voi ci pensate,
quello delle cassiere di banca femminista
è un sottoinsieme delle cassiere di banca;
quindi è più probabile
che sia una cassiera di banca.
Ecco, pensate: se questa cosa viene fatta
sulle nostre decisioni,
noi pensiamo di decidere
quello che vogliamo
e invece decidiamo quello
che ci vogliono far decidere.
I matematici e le matematiche
non fanno questo,
perché sanno distinguere
il probabile dal plausibile.
Perché noi, istintivamente, decidiamo
con il criterio della
somiglianza e del ricordo:
quell'immagine mi ricorda quel -
Allora, ecco che la matematica
ci regala questa libertà,
perché ci fa vedere
quali sono i dati accessori
e quali sono, invece, quelli fondamentali,
davanti a un problema
o davanti a una situazione
di tipo personale.
Una volta, una mia studentessa mi disse:
Prof, sa che con la matematica
ho risolto il problema con mio padre?
Non riuscivo a comunicare con lui.
A quel punto, ho fatto
come fa la matematica:
mi sono estraniata,
ho guardato il problema nell'insieme
e ho cercato le relazioni
tra i dati che avevano
e quali erano i dati fondamentali.
E a quel punto ho deciso
di scrivere una lettera,
e magicamente ho trovato il canale
per parlare con mio padre.
Ecco, la matematica
ci fa fare proprio questo:
trovare le relazioni tra i dati,
tra delle informazioni
che diventano qualcosa per noi:
pensate, durante la pandemia,
quanti dati e quante informazioni.
E noi dovevamo costruire dei modelli
che ci permettessero di stare meglio.
Dati slegati, ancora oggi lo vediamo.
Ecco: dove si formano questi modelli?
Nella nostra mente,
in questa cosa fantastica,
quella creatività matematica
che riesce a creare ordine dal disordine.
E serve ovunque, dicevo prima,
nei problemi personali.
È lo stesso atteggiamento
[che si ha] di fronte a una poesia.
Pensate, di fronte una poesia,
voi cosa fate innanzitutto?
Comprendere il contenuto
e il registro stilistico,
e poi andare a vedere
cosa dice quella poesia in generale.
E poi, dopo che avete fatto questo,
andate a capire
che cosa può servire a noi,
per comprendere sia
all'esterno sia noi stessi?
Ecco: la matematica fa la stessa cosa.
Così come, davanti a una persona
che parla un'altra lingua,
usiamo una lingua terza per comunicare;
e non importa la lingua terza,
importa l'informazione
che riusciamo a passarci.
Ecco: la matematica è questo,
è una lingua che ci permette
di andare in profondità,
di non fermarci all'ambiente,
alla parte esterna,
ma di comprendere
che cosa, realmente,
quella formula dice a noi,
così come la poesia;
quindi in fondo la matematica
ci allena, anche, all'empatia,
come fossimo in palestra:
non fermarci all'abito,
ma comprendere chi ci sta davanti.
Ecco: pensate ai pitagorici,
che cercavano di ridurre
i numeri irrazionali a razionali,
quella famosa radice di due
che non era trasformabile
in una frazione -
e uno studente di Pitagora
ha perso anche la vita,
perché diceva: non è
possibile trasformarli.
Invece loro no, perché erano
"egocentrati", potremmo dire oggi,
e quindi doveva essere possibile.
Invece si è scoperto che noi, oggi,
li teniamo così come sono,
quindi quando facciamo radice di due
per radice di tre facciamo radice di sei.
Non li trasformiamo nei decimali,
rispettiamo la loro diversità;
e rispettando la loro diversità
possiamo fare una marea di cose.
Ecco: la matematica è tutto questo.
È utilità, è rispetto della diversità
e bellezza intellettuale
che ci porta alla verità,
alla luce della verità
sostenuta dalle evidenze.
Ecco: alcuni anni fa
incontrai Paolo, vi ricordate?
Quello studente che mi fece la domanda:
"A che cosa serve la matematica? "
Oggi, Paolo è parte
di uno studio importante
di avvocati, internazionale,
e lui mi ha detto:
"Prof, io ho usato quella risposta
e la uso tutti i giorni nel mio lavoro.
E nelle cause proprio importanti,
diverse, vengo mandato io,
proprio perché c'è qualcosa di nuovo.
E io che cosa faccio?
Cerco di trovare la soluzione che,
come dice la matematica, sta nell'oltre.
E trovata questa soluzione,
la metto a sistema."
Ecco: io oggi vorrei dare
una risposta anche a voi.
In questo periodo difficile
di pandemia, come uscirne?
Ecco: seguendo la via della matematica.
Sapendo che c'è un limite,
ma che il limite lo possiamo superare
grazie alla fantasia,
e allo spirito critico,
come ci insegna la matematica.
Nel rispetto e nella
valorizzazione delle diversità,
sapendo che lo possiamo fare,
che dobbiamo immaginare una idea nuova
e dobbiamo dimostrarla tutti assieme.
Ecco, cari amici e care amiche:
a questo serve, la matematica.
(Applausi)